miami
[Applause]
but nine straight points for portland a
run that just ended thanks to jimmy
butler who gets hit with a technical
foul yeah you just can't be that overly
demanding oh jimmy butler's thrown out
of the game
jimmy butler got the first technical
from musa dagger and then courtney
kirkland teed him up for a second quick
technical and that ends the night for
butler after just 15 minutes
somebody gonna have to shoot the free
throw four
that is too quick on that second
technical foul you got to let the player
full off after that look he went at the
first official he deserved that
technical
right there he deserves that technical
and he really does but he walked away
there
and why is he picking up the second
technical at that point he's
walking away to the free-throw line let
him calm down if he continues to go back
at that official
there's no question you're right johnny
he deserved that technical
[Applause]
that's a big loss from miami and look
jimmy struggled a bit here early that's
why he's so emotional on this play this
is an n1 opportunity for him
um you know with the foul
and one but when they when they double t
him there quickly on that second one he
gets tossed now someone's gonna come in
uh for the heat jimmy's not gonna be
able to finish the in one play here i
believe the the
blazers get to pick uh who they want off
the bench to shoot this free throw and
it's gonna be chris silva who's not a
great percentage free throw shooter and
is coming in ice cold not an easy
situation for chris silva he has yet to
shoot a free throw this year